mouna I need your help what you pay hold
on I can't do you are you breaking up Oh
so will you make some games for me or
what okay I'll call you back
Wario where gold is out now on 3ds and
with over 300 micro games packed in it
serves as a great way to revisit the
series 15 year history one that's full
of clever innovation it's smart use of
nintendo technology has made it the
perfect guinea pig for new and creative
ideas through 8 games across almost as
many platforms Wario has always been on
the cutting edge of Nintendo's new
technologies let's rewind the year was
2003 the Governator was elected in
California Apple launched iTunes and we
got our fifth Mario Party that year
Nintendo also launched Wario Ware mega
microgames on the Game Boy Advance at
that time the Game Boy Advance was the
place to play critically acclaimed but
time consuming RPGs like Golden Sun Fire
Emblem
and pokemon ruby and sapphire then Wario
came crashing in on his motorbike with
this collection of mini-games
but the word mini doesn't even quite fit
hence the new term micro games coined by
the dev team in in Tendo our indie 1
it's a concept you can understand pretty
much immediately in just a few seconds
you get a command and a scenario and
have to figure out what to do often
timing just a single button press at a
dash of meme or the humor like
nose-picking or smiling food and you've
got yourself a recipe you can enjoy over
and over again making the simple games
not so repetitive but Wario wasn't the
only mascot for the series 9 vault is an
audience stand-in for Nintendo fans his
collection of micro games serves as a
nostalgia trip for kids of the NES and
Super NES eras remix in classics like
Legend of Zelda and Super Mario Brothers
into rapid fire challenges sounds a lot
like nes remix on the Wii U right
Nintendo played off that nostalgia first
with Wario Ware and would do it again a
year later with the classic NES series
which ported first
generation Nintendo games to the GBA the
very games that had their first comeback
in WarioWare just one year later we
would get WarioWare twisted the crazy
innovation this time was a cartridge
with a built-in gyro sensor which meant
you had to complete many of the games
using simple motion controls this was
two full years before the we brought
motion controls to the living room
twisted was certainly inspired by kirby
tilt and tumble and that did predate
warioware by a few years but Wario did
punt the little pink puffball out of the
way when we came around with an
innovative launch game as Nintendo has
want to do with its first party games
Wario Ware smooth moves demonstrated the
full potential of the technology with
over twenty different uses of the Wii
mote across its minigames there was the
typical sword slashing and pointing
Shore but smooth moves mix things up
with more creative poses like holding
the remote above your head rotating in
your palm like a joystick or even
completely discarding it only to quickly
draw at a moment later that quick draw
would be featured again when a certain
switch launch game came around one to
switch features many of those same
motion configurations and takes things
to the next level with new technology
like the joy Kahn's HD Rumble but the
WarioWare influence is clear in the
gameplay humor and even the art style
whether it was motion control at home or
on the go Wario Ware showed Nintendo
fans the possibilities
that wasn't Wario's only launch game
either WarioWare touched came alongside
the DS
and as you'd expect it once again showed
off what in tendo's tech could do
minigames capitalized on the touchscreen
with taps drags rubs and all other
manner of stylus control touchscreen
gaming continued to be a Nintendo staple
through the three DS Wii U and now
switch but the DS did at first and
WarioWare proved it could work Wario's
final outing on the DS continued to
innovate WarioWare DIY tells you pretty
much everything you need to know in the
title you can make your own micro games
music and comics the level of
customization here was unrivaled by any
other Nintendo game at the time and it
wouldn't be matched until a full six
years later when super mario maker
graced the Wii U and now a full nine
years after DIY you can look at lab oohs
toy con Garage and still see Nintendo
capitalizing on the creativity of its
fans with a game where you're only
limited by your own imagination it's a
fantastic concept that Wario Ware first
brought to the workshop over these last
15 years games in the vein of Wario Ware
have certainly come around Frobisher
says and work-time fun had their 15
minutes of fame and Wario Ware designer
Kazuyoshi ozawa went on to create rhythm
tengoku an amazing rhythm series that
found success in its own niche
now it's 2018 Nintendo still capitalizes
on nostalgia with the likes of the NES
classic the switch still makes smart use
of touch and motion controls and through
it all Wario Ware is still here offering
the same goofy micro games it brought to
the table 15 years ago and it's still
the antithesis of those hundred
hour-long rpgs and open-world adventures
in today's video game scene in the time
it'll take you to get through the
Witcher threes introductory chapter you
can finish the entire critical path of
mega microgames
so if you've never experienced the joy
of the Wario air series I'd encourage
you to try it out it'll only take a few
seconds for Wario and his pals to charm
their way into your heart
[Music]